[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be discussing the relationship
between Voldemort and the guinea an
unusual bond between man and snake as we
know Nagini was born a female human
maledictis my addictive refers to
someone who suffers from a blood
malediction a dark curses passed on
through generations family members
neguin e's blood malediction meant that
she was destined to turn into a snake
becoming less human and more snake each
and every day for a period you possess
the ability to transform at will but
that slips over time a blood malediction
is an awful and inescapable curse that
eats away at you
slowly stripping away your identity
before transforming into a snake
permanently and eventually becoming a
Horcrux the Guinea was a shy quiet kind
woman who was unfortunately mistreated
by the circus a carnist Nagini was not
evil from the guinea and even attempted
to save Creedence bare bone from being
manipulated by Grindelwald she would
eventually help in defeating grinev old
siding with Newt Scamander
and others in an attempt to end the
global whistling war the snake form of
New Guinea was first introduced in the
Goblet of Fire where she's described as
eating the body of mongrel Frank price
though we don't have an exact date it's
speculated that New Guinea and Voldemort
met in the forests of Albania sometime
in the 1980s at this point the Guinea
would have likely fully assumed her
snake-like form and Voldemort would have
been hiding in his disembodied State
it's hard to say how their initial
interaction would have gone there we
know a couple of things about Voldemort
that would help him in interacting with
a giant snake firstly Voldemort is able
to possess animals and we know that
later on in the books and films he can
possess Nagini so I would imagine the
possession was part of their original
interaction secondly Voldemort is the
descendant of Salazar Slytherin this
means that his connection to snakes is
strong and
he can even communicate with them
because of his ability to speak
Parseltongue fast-forward to that
interaction
I'm sure Nagini a lost maledictis the
void of communication would have leaked
at the opportunity to communicate with
someone else anyone else it was someone
who could finally understand her someone
who she could tell her story to I'm sure
that Voldemort would have quickly
realized that she was a maledictis
immediately elevating her above the
level of just some snake effectively
peeking his interest at this point both
Dakini and Voldemort were likely a bit
lost Nagini stuck in a snake form devoid
of interaction and Voldemort nearly
defeated and had a bit of a loss for
what to do next it's only natural the
two would parent torn up each of them
having something to offer to the other
Nagini was instrumental in Lord
Voldemort survival before he could be
restored to his body her venom was even
used in an elixir that helped him to
survive it was one of the primary
ingredients in a potion that he used to
rebuild his strength in addition to that
she helped him commit a vast number of
murders and she even became one of his
Horcruxes when Voldemort murdered Bertha
Jorkins in 1994 by the time Nagini had
become a Horcrux
she had been at Voldemort side for a
long time her humble shy and gentle
nature was no more and she became a
weapon for Lord Voldemort the man to
which she was completely loyal because
she was one of Voldemort's Horcruxes she
shared a telepathic bond with him and
was even capable of speaking to him over
vast distances despite his evil nature
she thought very highly of him and she
only became more and more like him after
they considerable time together
Dumbledore had this to say a Voldemort's
relationship when the ghini I think he
is perhaps as fond of her as he can be
of anything he certainly likes to keep
her close and has an unusual amount of
control over her even for a past month
so it wasn't just Nagini that cared for
Voldemort he had strong feelings for her
as well
feelings that he didn't have for anyone
else she may have been the only thing
that he truly cared about and that's it
for this video what do you guys think
how do you think Voldemort and Nagini
met how was their relationship
established
let me know down in the comment section
below if you guys enjoyed the video
please give it a like
until next time your way sir Harry
[Music]